Hey, this is kind of funny. I was on the Dr. Phil
show like I didn't go anywhere, but a clip of the
show was on the Dr. Phil show. And this is really
funny. It ended up being very underwhelming. I'm
going to play the clip for you. Dr. Phil's show
producers contacted me months ago saying, David,
we loved your interview about the addictiveness
of casinos with an author who wrote about this
named Natasha Dorsainvil. And we want to use
a clip for the show. We're going to feature
you and Intershop. Can we do it? Sure. Yeah.
My only requirement is let me air the clip
on my show without filing a copyright claim. I
think my audience would get a kick out of it.
Months of legal work and negotiations and
paperwork I was imagining. Wow. I mean, this
there's so much lawyer time going into the. I'm
sure this is going to be like a big feature,
I think I'm on screen about four seconds,
OK, don't look away because you might
miss me. This is an episode, I guess,
about gambling problems. Take a look.
Casinos are deliberately designed
like a maze to trap and confuse you.
There's no clocks on the wall. You cannot help
but be overwhelmed by the bombardment of sounds
like you are getting a little dose of
gambling in your brain every three seconds.
It's a gambling IVI, so you try to crowd objects,
bring the ceiling height down and create a sense
of sort of clutter, coziness, confusion.
You're going to hear ding, ding, ding, ding.
It's going to light up flash. What if those
jingles and bells and whistles are actually
that encourage you to make risky decisions?
You go into that Transat zone, that box,
nobody can touch you. You have escape from
reality. No one can ask you for anything.
So that that's it, those four seconds, pretty
underwhelming. So to me, the shock is the amount
of paperwork for a few seconds of me on Dr. Phil..
It must be a lawyer's dream to be clearing rights
for these shows. If they spent two months, three
months of legal work to get four seconds of me,
I can't even imagine what's going on with, you
know, copyrighted music or whatever else. So
that was me on Dr. Phil.. I don't know what
else to say. Maybe maybe it's interesting
in some way. But the back story is lots and
lots of legal negotiations to make it happen.